Speaker 1: All right, let's go back to the phones
via discord, not really phones and talk to a few
more people. You can find it at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Let's go next to let's
go to Alacrity from Alabama. You're on the air.
Speaker 5: Greetings, Mr. Pakman is a pleasure
to be here, I shall be swift. I come here
because I seek your opinion of a relatively
new tax proposal called the Chaos Tax and
to briefly debate its merits as a gesture
of good faith. Know that I will judge
your arguments judiciously, OK? Anyway,
that chaos tax is a tax proposal where you have
different revenue pools and you tailor the rates
to that revenue pool and it is a range of rates
bounded and the rates are tailored to minimize
compliance costs and administrative costs. And it
is called a chaos tax because within those bounds,
there is randomization, an application
like, say, from people who pay it. And an
example of revenue pool would be just financial
transactions or sales, something like that. And
this does sound a bit of a bizarre proposal,
but there is precedent for randomization and
tax proposals. For example, there was this one
type of tax, I forget the exact name eludes me,
but it was a sort of profits tax, an example
given on the source that I was reading is that.
You know, is that it was applying it to
corporations and that's the randomization
helped to minimize the cost of either compliance
or actually just minimize dead weight loss due
to economic distortions from the tax. I'm just
wondering what you think of a tax of this nature.
Speaker 1: I don't even know that I understand
that. Are you saying that for a given group like,
for example, corporations, the tax rate
they pay is subject to basically chance,
where some corporations randomly pay 11
percent and others pay 17 percent and
you don't know until you file your taxes?
Speaker 5: It wouldn't be like that, no,
because the entire point of the tax, which
it would only be applied to pools such as
financial transactions, where the cost of trying
to account for it, like you said, will be lower
than if you just didn't bother trying to account
for it. For example, there was this one case,
I believe it was from the 70s, where this
person made millions of dollars skimming
from the rounding errors in bank transactions. So
the tax is meant to be is not meant to be filed by
the people paying it for that very reason,
because in that case, the one that you just cited.
If you actually have to file
at the cost of not accounting
for a greater than just not ignoring it, you
Speaker 1: know, I apologize. I have no idea what
you're talking about. I just this may be a mike. I
may have a cognitive deficit. I just have no clue
at all how what you're talking about would work.
So let me study it and then I'll follow up, OK?
Speaker 5: Well, it is a tax proposal
of my own creation so I can send you
the literature that I have compiled.
Speaker 1: This is something you've
come up with. Yes. OK, all right, good.
Send me the literature and then you know,
we will. We will. We will figure it out. OK, come
on. All right then. All right. Thank you very much